تحدق دعاء الغضبان في صور زوجها واطفالها
الثلاثه وكانها لا تريد ان تصدق حول
الفاجعه لقد قتلوا جميعا فقد الدعاء
عائلتها الصغيره هنا في جمال سوريا بفعل
الزلزال ولم يتبقى لها سوى حزن يبدو انه
لن ينضب طلعني اخي
بعدين شو اسمه
جابولي ابني قالوا لي عايش
صلاه الفجر قالوا مات
لعائشه قصه اخرى مع حفيدتها الصغيره تمشي
قرب منزلها المدمر في بلده الاتارب بريف
حلب حيث تعيش في ماوى للطوارئ بعد ان
شردها الزلزال حرمتها الكارثه من الوصول
الى الخدمات الطبيه لعلاج امراض الكبد
المعين الوحيد
يعني ربما شاب ربما اب ربما جد عم يعيل
العيله ارامل واولاد صار تحت الانقاض ضعف
الزلزاله من ماساه عائشه وكثير من النساء
شمال البلاد وهن اصلا من الفئات الاشد
ضعفا كثير منهن ارامل وكثير منهن نازحات
في الاصل منذ سنوات طويله
في نساء هلق ما عندهم شيء
تتواصلوا الاحزان الى الجوار التركي هنا
في الريحانيه باولاتها تاي نسوه يشاركنا
دعاء وعائشه مصيبه نفسها والفقد نفسه
لا ندري هل يبكينا ازواجن اطفالهن اباءهن
ام شقيقتهم لكنها بالتاكيد جثث احبه بعضهن
فقدنا عائلاتهن ولم يتبقى لهن سوى طفل او
زوج وبعضهن لم يبقى لهن سوى الالم في
ماساه لا يعرف بعد كم عدد الضحايا النساء
فيها او من ترملنا او من اصبحنا بلا حتى
معيل